why I hate these
people I don't think it's possible to
sum up the state of this country better
than what happened last week Mike frier
a gay MP decided to leave politics
because of death threads from islamist
extremist he explained that he narrowly
avoided a confrontation with Ali Hari
Ali an extremist who was given a life
sentence for murdering conservative MP
David Ames friia represents a
constituency with a significant jewi
population and has supported Israel
following the October 7th terrorist
attack by Hamas he told the male he
believes his views on Israel have led to
him being targeted this is bad you might
be thinking it's an assault on an
elected representative's right to
represent his constituents and therefore
an attack on our democracy it is of
course but this is not remotely the
beginning first of all freya's
colleagues reacted in a manner that
instantly brought back memories of the
murder of s David Ames by an islamist in
2021 one when they responded by talking
about online hate as if their colleague
had been murdered by a tweet the
reaction of these same people to free
his announcement has been to ignore the
real nature of the threat he talked
about and instead claim MPS must be
nicer to each other of course I want a
nicer politics and I want us to treat
each other in a much better way than
we've been seeing secondly the other
story in the news last week was of Abdul
Shakur aidi an illegal immigrant who
arrived in Britain from Afghanistan on a
lry in 2016 his application for Asylum
was denied that same year and then
denied again in 2018 it was only after
he had committed an unspecified sex
offense in 2018 that he'd worked out
what to do he converted to Christianity
and was eventually given asylum on the
basis that Afghanistan was an unsafe
country for a faithful follower of
Christ however despite the peaceful
teachings of his new adopted religion
last week aidi maimed a mother and her
two daughters in a chemical attack that
also injured five police officers and
several members of the public who
attempted to help the victims at the
time of recording eidi remains On The
Run why was he not deported when he
first arrived illegally why was he not
removed after the first two failed
Asylum applications how on Earth was he
given Asylum once he had committed a sex
offense that resulted in him being
placed on the sex offenders register
these are the questions most sane people
will be asking they're not however the
questions your elected representatives
are asking instead conservative MP
Caroline NOS participated in discussion
on BBC News night in which she talked
bravely about the number of
microaggressions she faced as a woman I
was surprised to hear how many
microaggressions that you face and have
always faced every day women will face
misogyny and microaggressions if you're
a woman of color it will be worse and we
have to do better while labor MP Bel
rera Addy explained that eid's Asylum
status was not the issue of concern his
Asylum status though is not really the
issue of concern the issue is that he
would attack uh a woman and her children
in in this particular way I try very
hard not to Harbor hate in my heart for
anyone but I truly and deeply hate these
people I hate the people who allow our
country to be taken advantage of by
violent scum who should never have been
here I hate the people who are too weak
and too soft to protect their fellow
citizens after being elected to do so
truth be told I hate them even more than
I hate the terrorists extremists and
foreign criminals who take advantage of
them and because of them they take
advantage of us because the terrorists
extremists and criminals are what they
are I expect them to murder rape and M
but these people whom we elected to
protect us know what's going on and are
just too pathetic and cowardly to do
anything about it but worry not the
conservative government have got it all
under control how is it possible that
someone turned down twice for
Asylum who then commits a sexual offense
or more than one sexual offense is
granted Refugee status by tribunal how
is that possible well I think that's
something that more than one person are
asking as as you say and I think my
understanding is the Home Secretary as
asked for all the details but this is
not really about
Asylum if you enjoy these videos they
are available on my substack earlier
than they are here check out the link
below before you go let me take a minute
to recommend a longevity supplement by
Vero in our recent interview with Tim
Urban he said we should be talking about
longevity and Longevity science
researchers like the biologist David
Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell being
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body high NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damaged
DNA and increase energy production in
your brain immune system and muscles but
as you grow old your body's NAD levels
go down and you can't take NAD as a
supplement because it's too big for your
cells to absorb that's why Verso cell
being contains nmn Resveratrol and TMG
these three molecules work together to
increase NAD plus levels if you want to
read more about this check out the
scientific research Linked In the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its product product to
guarantee that you're getting exactly
what you're paying for so if you want to
join me you can get 15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to save 15%
off your
[Music]
order